if if the cheating stats are similar the
if we look at the abuse statistics women
are more abusive towards men than men
are towards women because think about it
women can get away with it more
that's why I believe it because if you
take away the consequences for someone
they're going to do it more I'm not
saying that women like like men and
women are equally capable of abuse but
women don't always go to jail for I mean
look at what happened in Miami with that
that only fans model she killed her
boyfriend yeah and she's walking free
right now if the roles were reversed it
wouldn't happen right so if you take
away the consequences in a society
they're going to do it more like to me
to me that makes sense so it that's why
he's saying that it's
the woman's fault because we both have
problems but the women is the one
leaving